welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus docker
if the world plunges into a nuclear
conflict one possible consequence could
be nuclear winter which is a global
decrease in temperatures leading to a
collapse of agriculture
on this episode I'm joined by Brian too
Brian is an atmospheric scientist at the
University of Colorado Boulder and he
has spent decades researching nuclear
winter we talk about how nuclear winter
Could Happen what the consequences might
be and how Humanity could avoid this
catastrophe
along the way Brian has fascinating
stories to share about asteroids
volcanoes and what we might learn about
nuclear winter from studying the
extinction of the Dinosaurs
I really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you will too here's Brian too
Brian welcome to the podcast thank you
guys
when did you begin working on nuclear
winter
and when I began in the early 1980s I
was uh at the time working for NASA and
I had done a lot of work on how
volcanoes affect the climate we were
worried at that time about supersonic
aircraft affecting the climate and
various other issues about space shuttle
engines
and about that time
the
people at Berkeley discovered that an
asteroid collision had killed the
dinosaur 66 million years ago
and so I started working on that problem
and um there's a layer of material all
around the Earth
left from that Collision you could put
your finger on it if you want to and
various platons about a centimeter thick
and it's full not only of asteroidal
material but also smoke
and uh so there's 66 million year old
smoke covering the Earth
um from 66 million years ago
and in order to make all that smoke you
had to basically burn everything in the
surface of the planet all the trees all
the grasses and probably even some of
their Roots things underneath the
surface soil
and a very controversial idea that an
asteroid impacted killed the dinosaurs
this violated basic geological ideas of
uniformitarianism so geology hundreds of
years ago have been dominated by
religious Dogma
floods from Noah and things like that
and um geology Community it eventually
shown that you know most of the things
we see like mountains and oceans and
things like that have just evolved very
slowly and so it's hard to see it in a
human life but everything is happening
now and it just accumulates over long
periods of time so they were very
opposed in geology to any catastrophic
uh pointed view like an asteroid killing
the dinosaurs it went back to this
religious thing where catastrophes were
like God flooding the Earth and Noah
surviving in the dark you know but
actually these asteroid collisions are
not uh sudden uh events they are
constantly going on there's about 40
tons of
debris falling of the Earth every day
mostly in tiny little particles my
asteroids are constantly bombarding the
planet there was a big explosion of 400
kiloton explosion over a Sheila beans
Russia a few years ago that
injured a thousand people you know that
was a an object about 20 meters in size
you know a fifth of a football field or
something so it wasn't a very big
asteroid but things like that occur
every
few dozens of years somewhere in the
earth and in fact there's an Hiroshima
sized explosion in the Earth's
atmosphere every year or two from
incoming asteroids
when we go back and history to bigger
and bigger events the moon was formed
from an asteroid collision with the
Earth and in that case the asteroid was
a little bit bigger than Mars
that at any rate I give a talk about
this just after the discovery of the
asteroid killing the dinosaurs
explaining how it happened and
how they died from all this debris being
put into the atmosphere which at that
time we thought was rocks from the
asteroid just we didn't realize there
was all this smoke there for quite a few
years at any rate someone at this
meeting said well what about nuclear
weapons they put a lot of stuff in the
atmosphere you should go think about
those
um so I called up a friend of mine Rich
Turco uh and said that you know hey Rich
you know and maybe we should think about
nuclear weapons again we thought about
him before and hadn't really found
anything but we spent more time at it we
thought well all the dust raised from
these nuclear explosions could do
something
and then we came across some paper by
Paul krutzen and John Burks pointing out
that cities would be set on fire
by nuclear weapons exploding and Rich
happened to work for a company that knew
a lot about this because they studied
fire some nuclear weapons
um so we um
decided we should look into the smoke
from the burning cities
so Christian and Burks had suggested
that there would be forest fires set by
nuclear bombs going off
so a nuclear weapon going off is like
bringing a piece of the sun down to the
Earth you know says the same kind of
thing the sun produces its light from
thermonuclear explosion is basically
Fusion reactions in its core and so
we're bringing a little piece of the sun
down to the Earth and when the nuclear
weapon goes off there's a bright burst
of light
and it's very intense and it can start
fires out at considerable distance
something very energetic explodes and
lights a bunch of fire where where from
smoke Rises that blocks out the sunlight
coming to Earth exactly and that's that
mechanism is shared between the asteroid
impact that killed the dinosaurs and a
potential catastrophe scenario of
nuclear winter
that's exactly right so the
the problem messiah's point of view of
studying nuclear winter is you can't do
any experiments you certainly don't want
to do things
and uh and so you have to go look for
natural analogs and the extinction of
the dinosaurs is a natural analog
because you had an immense Global fire
there put a huge amount of smoke into
the atmosphere the fire has probably
killed the dinosaurs and the smoke block
sunlight temperatures fell but the
oceans had mass extinctions it wasn't
just the dinosaurs 75 percent of the
species on the planet that we know about
perished and they see that probably very
suddenly within a decade or so
or less
so in the oceans the light went out
photosynthesis stopped so plants
couldn't produce any
more food in the oceans and
um so the fish and zooplankton which ate
the phytoplankton starve to death
and so this is a very definite parallel
with what would happen after a nuclear
war
how long did it last do we know how long
it lasted
well it's hard to tell from the
geological record there about the
closest you can tell is that from dating
the record is about 50 000 years which
is not anywhere near the time scale that
this happened on so we know there's this
layer that I mentioned covering the
whole earth and we know how big the
particles are in that layer and they all
fell out of the atmosphere within about
a year or two
and how perhaps extending as long as a
decade so we think the whole
thing that killed the dinosaurs and the
um
phytoplankton the fish in the oceans and
extinct at all kinds of plants in the
land and other animals as well you know
the whole thing probably only took about
10 years to occur so this is some
something that most people are familiar
with you have to eat every day maybe you
could go for a week or two without
starving to death but you know you have
to keep consuming food if the food
supply is suddenly eliminated you're in
big trouble
and the a potential nuclear winter would
take about as long about a decade
yeah so this nuclear winter is
so let's start again on how this happens
if you take two big pieces of uranium
the right type and you stick them
together they'll blow up
um and so the simplest bonds which were
built in the second world war were
nothing more than shoving two pieces of
uranium or plutonium together and making
them blow up Uh current weapons use
Fusion instead of fission and
um so you but you still get a lot of the
energy just out of the uranium with or
plutonium that's in the bomb
so this is EMC squared you know which
Einstein discovered you take a little
bit of mass
from from these elements
and um converted into energy and you can
release a tremendous amount of energy
that way so this starts fires when the
explosion occurs and of course it blows
buildings down and
uh radiates people with uh high energy
particles of light to kill them and so
there are a bunch of terrible things
that happen if you're near Ground Zero
but the one that covers the biggest area
is the fires
so if you looked at a picture of
Hiroshima after the bomb was dropped in
Japan I had in the second world war you
see this huge debris field
and um that some of it is because the
blast broke some buildings down but most
of it is because there was a huge fire
there
and then the fire actually released a
thousand times as much energy as a bomb
exploding did
so it's hard to imagine how how powerful
these big fires are
photographs of the bottom you can see
the mushroom cloud everybody's familiar
with after a nuclear explosion
and but a few hours later after that
gone away there's a huge pyrocumulus
so we call them fire or thunderstorms
I'm singing frequently now and I've just
fires and forests you know we're having
all these fires all over the world and
um in 2017 there was a pirate cumulus in
British Columbia from a big flyer and um
right around the New Year 2020 there was
a set of big fires in Australia that
have these big pyreneos big fire
thunderstorms and these are important
because they take the smoke
from burning a forest and push it up to
high high into the atmosphere
into what we call the stratosphere but
if you put smoke into the stratosphere
carry it up in these Thunders
Thunder fire storms the smoke is in a
place where it never rains never rains
in the stratosphere and so the smoke can
stay there for years
and another thing that was suggested in
the 1980s would be that the sun would
shine in the Smoke which is very black
um you can see a fireplace or something
like that or you're going in places burn
you see all the black stuff all over the
place you know just Elemental carbon so
I'd like charcoal and The Sun Shines and
that it warms it adhesive and that heats
the air and it rises
and in the models from the 1980s the
smoke Rose to the top of the models
which wasn't very high didn't have good
computers in the 1980s
but you know later work and in the 1990s
and the computers are better in 2000 era
and the smoke was rising up to about 80
kilometers
above the ground so very very high
and surprisingly we actually observed
this now in the 2017 and in 2020 after
these big forest fires the smoke was put
in
just at the lower part of the Stratos
for about 12 kilometers above the ground
and the Sun was shining on that smoke
and heating it and after a week or two
it Rose to 20 or 30 kilometers
that altitude was limited because there
wasn't very much smoke it was just a
forest fire but it did the same thing
these models are predicted 20 years
earlier and that you know we saw this
smoke hang around for 20
for a year from satellites so we could
observe this very well and it did all
sorts of other interesting little things
in the stratosphere like quickly spread
itself out over the Earth so it didn't
just hover over the fires it became a
hemispheric or Global phenomena very
quickly
just as the models predicted so the
models are confirmed in a sense by the
the natural events that are analogies
for what would happen if nuclear bombs
went off exactly what about the energies
involved what is how should we compare
the energy involved in an asteroid
impact
or a volcanic eruption with the energies
involved in nuclear weapons is it is the
right comparison between the energies
involved with the fires that follow a
nuclear war or the setting off a nuclear
weapon or is it is is the right
comparison between the the energy
directly involved in the in the nuclear
weapon explosion itself
well that's a good question and the
first point I think is that energy is
what counts here and asteroids energy is
what counts and the energy goes like the
cube of the size so a one kilometer
asteroid uh compared to a 10 kilometer
asteroid which is what killed the
dinosaurs the 10 kilometer uh asteroid
has a thousand times as much energy
so that's why
it was so important because it had so
much energy
nuclear weapons so the energy of the
largest nuclear weapons in arsenals was
about one Megaton
one million it's equivalent energy of a
million tons of conventional explosives
so you can imagine trying to put a
million tons of explosive on an airplane
that's not going to happen that's why
nuclear weapons were developed you know
in the second world war we were bombing
cities indiscriminately and so the war
was fought was incendiary bombs on
cities and it took hundreds of hundreds
of airplanes to carry Bombs over it
burned resin to the ground and Hamburg
and 60 Japanese cities were firebombed
in the second world war and largely
destroyed by fires but you know you
split hundreds of airplanes out there or
if somebody's going to get killed in the
airplane crash
um and so one airplane can carry a
nuclear weapon and release the energy
for example the Hiroshima bomb was a 15
000 tons of explosive energy so and one
airplane could easily carry that bomb
but it would take fleets of them to
carry anything like 15 000 tons
so that's what nuclear weapons were
built to do destroy cities they're
inscriminate city killers
uh and that that was their purpose
but going on to this comparison of
volcanoes bombs and the asteroid
so a really large nuclear weapon would
have one Megaton of energy
the asteroid that killed the dinosaurs
was in the millions of tons of energy
you know so it's equivalent to millions
of nuclear weapons going off
and you know these the fires in a or a
volcano a really big volcano actually
could have an energy of a Megaton or
more
like we just had the hunger Tonga
eruption uh here uh last year
in Tonga which created sound waves that
were heard around the world and hurled
material pretty high in the stratosphere
you know that eruption was comparable to
a large nuclear weapon in terms of
energy release
but if we look at what really matters to
the climate it's the amount of this
black carbon that's put into the
atmosphere
and um a and a
nuclear war say between Russia and the
United States
we believe that about 150 million tons
of black carbon to be put into the
stratosphere
150 million tons
now that sounds a lot I like a lot
but and in the asteroid we think put in
15
000 million tons of black carbon and we
we know that because it's still there
it's in this little layer you'll put
your finger on you know so we know how
much black urban was put there
and as I said it would you'd have to
burn everything in the Earth service to
produce that much black carbon
the asteroid event would be an extreme
version of what would happen in the in
the case of or in the event of a nuclear
war between us and Russia if you go down
so we've got 15
000 million tons and 150 million tons so
the largest nuclear war is about a one
percent as much black carbon
so after the asteroid hit the planet we
think the amount of light
still reaching the surface of the planet
was
about as much as a moonless night
that was the light levels there were a
hundred million times lower than normal
so going from a forest fire in Canada
up to a nuclear war you're going up by
factor of a thousand and going from that
to the asteroids going up another factor
of a hundred
so we know what happens on either end of
a nuclear winter you know to go down
from a nuclear winter by a thousand well
you get some interesting phenomena that
a few weird scientists are tracking
following and they can see things
happening but the average person is
oblivious to it
um you know but if you go up by a factor
of a hundred thousand from a fire in
Canada because the extinction of the
dinosaurs and extinctions of the oceans
the nuclear wars in the middle there
somewhere
so it's amazing that lives even
continued after the asteroid impact 65
million years ago
well yeah it may have been
fortunate that uh more creatures were
not extincted when you take mammals for
example we're mammals and mammals had
been on the planet almost as long as the
dinosaurs that both originated
after another mass extinction event
about 250 billion years ago
which was not caused by an asteroid as
far as we can tell but anyway mammals
and dinosaurs both a rose about Den then
there was another Extinction event about
200 million years ago and at that point
the dinosaur became a dominant group on
the plant largest animals and so they
were they were the big guys on the
planet but mammals were the dominant
little guys on the planet and you know
so we had this niche of being little and
uh you know so there weren't a lot of
little dinosaurs around
um so anyway everybody went along
happily from there to 60 million years
ago uh with the Dinosaurs dominating and
the mammals being underfoot you know the
mammals were not out competing the
dinosaurs and that we were an
unsuccessful group if you want to think
of being big as being the winner
but then the asteroid hit the planet and
if you were a little
Mouse he'd kind of animal uh he probably
lives a hole in the ground in the first
place so you could avoid the dinosaurs
in the daytime
and um and most of our ancestors
probably did do that they lived in
little holes in the ground so you know
there's a huge fire going on over the
whole planet and which was set by
radiation coming down from the infalling
debris from the asteroid so when the
asteroid hit the planet it blew all
these rocks into the air they re-entered
the atmosphere of the whole planet and
friction they're like shooting stars you
know they burned up in the upper
atmosphere but instead of having one
Shooting Star a minute like you do or
something in a major
um shooting storm shooting star storm
instead of that on the ground we see 10
000 shooting stars per centimeter
squared
ten thousand per centimeter squared
well it all directed is covered in in
shooting stars
um you know that are a few centimeter or
a centimeter deep or something like that
did I hear that right ten thousand per
per centimeter squared right that's an
astonishing amount yeah well if you
looked up at the sky it wasn't one
little Trail every 30 seconds or
something like that the whole sky
look like a sheet of lava you know if
you were to see pictures of someone
standing next to a volcano and there's
this glowing red rock that they're
standing next to that's what it looked
like you know of course these rocks are
probably 40 or 50 kilometers above the
ground
so it wasn't like they were hitting you
in the head or burning You by touching
you they were radiating light
which is how forest fires move you know
forest fires have these giant flames and
they radiate light out ahead of them and
the light catches things on fire
and so that's how forest fires generally
started it's a really flammable stuff
like Dead Leaves and little grasses and
twigs and stuff you know there's some
something like a lightning strike sits
there and it starts off that little
debris on flame and then that catches
more little debris in the flame pretty
soon little force is on fire so that's
probably what happened in this case
to start the whole Forest on fire
and it might have been necessary for the
dinosaurs to go Instinct extinct for us
as Humanity to emerge as the dominant
species on Earth
which is also an interesting thought
exactly that probably is what happened
and that's how the dinosaurs themselves
Rose is they were not
here forever there was another set of
creatures that looked like crocodiles
that were the dominant species from 250
to 200 million years ago and they got
wiped out in the mass extinction uh the
crocodiles so then the dinosaurs took
over pins and dinosaurs of the dominant
ones until 66 million years ago
and you know they got burned up in this
fire probably mostly and the mammals
were hiding out Underground
and you can not far from where I live
there's a really nice million year of
succession of dynasty of mammal
Evolution where you can see these little
mammals surviving and they got bigger
and bigger and bigger pretty soon they
were as big as little dogs
um and you know sometimes it rapid
change the biota of the earth bottom of
this event but actually it was a close
call for mammals too it was probably
something like only 10 percent of the
mammal species that were alive
at the time of the dinosaurs actually
made it through this event
and so it wasn't wasn't easy to survive
even for mammals you know so there are
lots of different mammals that
disappeared there you know there are
lots of things like the ones we see in
Australia marsupials and rather strange
mammals uh at the time that were the
dominant type of mammals or the type of
mammal changed at the boundary as well
we definitely want to avoid going
instinct and and passing on the torch to
the the next dominant species whatever
that might be the Dolphins or whatever
and we'd have we want to maybe the most
likely way for us to go extinct is for
us to to
exterminate ourselves by for example a
scenario like nuclear winter we should
we should talk about how bad this
scenario would be how many would die as
a direct
as a direct result of the bombs and how
many would die and in the following
nuclear winter
right so there's a lot of interesting
Concepts here to think about you know
one of them is how long do species last
and so you know our species hasn't been
on the planet that long maybe a hundred
thousand years there were other hominids
before that but you know in general
um
hominids have only been around a million
years or something like that so we're a
relatively young species
uh you know tenth of a percent of the
life of the planet
um something like that uh M but
nevertheless the average lifetime of a
species on the planet is about four or
five million years
um there are some species like horseshoe
crabs have been around for a couple
hundred million years
so some some species have lived a long
time and most of them don't last that
long
you know and if I were to bed I'd say
human beings will not last as a species
for very much longer and it has nothing
to do with nuclear war I think what will
happen is that um
as we start to spread out to the planets
now if we start to colonize Mars
excuse me there were going to be people
that would live on Mars and they're
getting their children that grow up on
Mars and although we can go to Mars
where the gravity is about a third of
what it is here probably the people on
Mars are not going to be able to come
back because uh the gravity would be so
much higher on the earth that you know
they won't be able to stand up and move
around they won't their bodies will
don't have the muscle structure and the
bone structure to do that they'll
eventually end up evolving into a
different type of person but this is a
this is kind of a this could be a happy
a happy
way for the future to turn out if we
diverged into different branches and
evolved differently on different planets
um
then it it's it almost becomes a
question of semantics whether you want
to say that this is still Humanity
surviving or whether it's human the
descendants of humanity but there are
still intelligent beings with who who
might share at least some of our values
out there and it could go even faster it
could be that we learn how to intervene
on our genetics
or genome in such a way that we can
radically change ourselves but again
this would be this would be a positive
development in my eyes at least it would
it wouldn't be equivalent to to the the
death of of the species
exactly and this is how Carl Sagan got
into this so I got into it for the
dinosaurs and but Carl got into her
from uh intelligent life in the universe
so he was using What's called the Drake
equation in which he tried to figure out
well how many intelligent civilizations
should there be in our galaxy for
example and you know so back then we
didn't know very much in the 1980s about
how many planets there were but you take
the number of stars and then you guess
how many planets are around a star and
how many of those planets will be
habitable to people like us and you know
what what are the odds of Life rising
and what are the odds of intelligent
life arising you multiply all those
things together and you end up with a
Galaxy should be teeming with life
and you know since Pearl first looked
into those numbers with Frank Drake who
invented the direct equation and other
people we've actually determined that
there's probably a planet or two around
every Star and lots of them in the
so-called habitable zone
and um so we're all where are all of
these civilizations why aren't they
contacting us what do we know about them
and our girl was concerned that at the
end of this equation there was something
which was a lifetime of intelligent
civilization how long did it take before
it destroyed itself with nuclear weapons
a new fear War might be what Robin
Hansen The Economist uh
talked about as the great filter it
might be an event or a technology that's
invented that only a select few species
can can pass through
um which is the same as as putting in an
extra term in the Drake equation that
that
describes how long a species survives
for
yes I think that this is a serious
concern I I think right this minute we
find ourselves
and a really serious situation and for
three three reasons you know the and the
first reason is that um there are still
about 8 000 strategic nuclear weapons
uh in Russia and the United States
there's another 1200 scattered
through Britain and France and China
India and
Pakistan North Korea
so there was a 9 000 or more weapons out
there
for example if we just look at Russia at
the United States
there's only
300 cities in the United States with
more than a hundred thousand people
there's more than only 200 cities in
Russia with more than a hundred thousand
people
500 cities more than 100 000 people
eight thousand weapons
you can attack each city with a hundred
thousand people in it with 16 nuclear
weapons
and you can destroy us they're built to
destroy a city one weapon you don't need
to attack a town with a hundred thousand
people in it with 16 nuclear weapons
they're way too many nuclear weapons we
should try to describe the effects in
terms of human lives lost off a nuclear
winter
what what are the best estimates here
right so the best estimate and we have
at the moment
um is that a war between India and
Pakistan
which are two nuclear States
that are unable to solve their political
differences over Kashmir
and so they keep threatening each other
to have a nuclear war
and they're also rapidly building their
arsenals Pakistan is um
could by the end of the decade be the
third largest nuclear power in the world
in terms of the number of nuclear
weapons
um who would think Pakistan has that
many so right now India and Pakistan
each probably have about 150 nuclear
weapons
and we're believed believed by the end
of the decade that they could each have
300 nuclear weapons
there's no treaties there we don't know
how big their weapons are
um
and so there's a lot of uncertainty
about how big the weapons are
that we know we think how many weapons
they have for comparison France and
Britain have two or three hundred
chairman has about 300. anyway a war
between India and Pakistan we have
calculated would kill 50 to 150 million
people
and India and Pakistan just because of
the bombs blowing up you know so you
drop a bomb in a heavily populated city
like New Delhi Hong Kong you know you
could kill a million people with one
moderate size nuclear weapons in one
city that's densely populated
Beijing London all those big cities you
lose hundreds of thousands to a million
people
the Korean had densely populated it is
from one weapon with a hundred kiloton
yield which is the smallest weapon on an
American submarine
so an American submarine
could have about 90
nuclear warheads on it the smallest of
which is a hundred kilotons
that produces a thousand times
the energy explosive energy of the
Hiroshima bomb one submarine has a
thousand times the explosive power of
the horosium of bomb
so anyway we think that India and
Pakistan 50 to 150 million people would
die in those countries however the smoke
removes
bombs blowing up and burning those
cities
which we believe would end up to be
somewhere between 5 million tons and
about 50 million tons of smoke
five million to 50 million at the upper
end that's a third as much as a U.S
Russia War
and and we think that the temperatures
around the world would start falling
within days of all the smoke being put
in the atmosphere and the smoke would
spread over the northern hemisphere in a
couple weeks it spread all the way to
Antarctica within once some whole planet
would be covered with the stuff it would
reduce sunlight by tens of percent
and um it'd be like going into winter
and um the temperatures would fall in
fact we think you'd have even sub Ice
Age glacial temperatures
from a war between India and Pakistan
and we think you probably would kill
one to three billion people depending on
how big the weapons are that they have
you lower the temperatures and
agriculture starts to fail
and this is even more extreme in a war
between the United States and Russia
we think there that you reduce sunlight
to about 70 percent of the normal
um we looked at Ukraine and Iowa
so those are two grain growing regions
that are produce a lot of the grain that
people eat and in both cases after a war
between the United States and Russia
which would also involve NATO NATO
always thinks it's left out of this NATO
will be bombed all over the place by
hundreds of Russian weapons that are not
even counted in these eight thousand
um
that in Iowa and the Ukraine
every day would have temperatures below
freezing
every day for a couple years
it would take years or any day to have a
temperature that stayed above freezing
all day long you're not going to grow
anything in that kind of condition
that's a true nuclear winter when the
temperatures are stable and freezing you
know there'll be snow on the ground all
the time probably and it'd be like a
normal winter nothing would grow you
mentioned Iowa and Ukraine specifically
because Iowa and Ukraine produce a lot
of the crops for the whole world exactly
they do you know their major middle
attitude green grain regions
so in these kinds of scenarios of places
that are hurt the most agriculturally or
countries that are at middle and high
latitudes like even a small War causes a
large fraction of the people in Russia
to die from starvation the world has 60
days of grain and storage two months
not seven years it has 60 days on
average big city London for example or
any other big city has enough food to
feed people for less than a week
yeah so where's it come from like it's
transported in all the time from some
other place where people are actively
growing Foods you know like the United
States is wintertime guilt kinds of food
from Mexico and Australia Chile yeah
um South America the same thing happens
worldwide that we depend on Global
Transport to bring food in all the time
to places where it's being consumed and
from where it's being grown and if you
have a nuclear war between the United
States and Russia the transportation is
going to go to nothing the oil refiners
are all going to be destroyed now there
won't be any way of transporting food
there won't be a way to grow it because
it's too cold to grow it and so people
will start starving within a month or
two you know so there are people who
are trying to figure out well how can
you how can you prevent a disaster like
this what could you do how can you be
ready for that you know I've said
there's no way you're going to have
agriculture starts to ring up seven
years of food even now the Ukraine is
having trouble because they have last
year's grain and storage so they have no
place to put this year's grain and so
that you're going to use lose a year
of growth there unless people solve this
to help them somehow which there don't
seem to be making much progress in doing
what about
um I know there are some projects
attempting to grow food without sunlight
um with and that might be interesting to
look into if if we are attempting to
prepare for worst case scenarios here
yeah I think that if you had time to
probably do something
like that
um so you know you could eat mushrooms
or something they often grow in Dark
Places or you could Harvest kelp from
the oceans we've also analyzed Fisheries
you know there's just not officially
only supplies a small fraction of the
food people eat now
um and you it's already over harvested
you know so you're not going to save
yourself by eating fish
but of course most of the people on the
planet would have died probably within a
month or two or three or four from
starvation
um and so you don't have that big of a
population left to seed but also you
don't have that big of a population left
to go growing and saying you don't have
any
oil or gasoline to power your tractors
and you know so I there's there's a big
problem here in terms of surviving this
just in terms of you only have a short
period of time to start growing food
because there's so little in storage uh
and you know adapting and under those
circumstances
um to some new agricultural techniques
or new agricultural
areas you know trying to start growing
more in the tropics for example and you
know that be very very difficult to do
in the short time you have available
it's something we would need to have the
foresight to do beforehand and attempt
to be prepared for disaster which is not
something that Humanity as a whole is
typically great at doing
yeah I think the global climate problem
that shows that we have no capability of
taking care of future problems
uh even though they're obvious
um you know people have vested interest
in the status quo they don't want to
change
now that and they'll resist any such
thing and you can see the difficulty in
storing a lot of grain and things like
that it is very expensive
and uh hopefully you'd never need it and
So eventually people will be tired of
paying for it
we've had nuclear the threat of nuclear
weapons hanging over our heads for many
decades and I guess because of the cold
war many people have this kind of they
know about the potential harm from
nuclear weapons and many people also now
know about the potential harms from
nuclear winter
because the research has been ongoing
since the 80s why is it so difficult to
remain focused on this thread and and do
something about it over the long term it
seems that that
humans simply forget about it or do
something else with their lives instead
of solving this
problem that might kill billions of
people
well I think there's two different
things that happened
and so uh in the 1960s there were a lot
of above ground nuclear weapons tests
that were going on and they were
polluting the planet with radioactive
cesium and
things like that and it was getting into
children's teeth you know you could see
that you know it was being concentrated
in cow milk because they eat grass it
had to radiation fall on it and then it
was being concentrated into bones people
were highly aware of this because it was
a huge fight of abandoning these above
ground tests and of course A lot of
people are still remember the second
world war at that time
um you know but uh people continue to
worry about it because the Cuban Missile
Crisis and the conflict in the cold war
between the United States and the Soviet
Union
divided the launch of the nuclear
weapons tests not trigger a nuclear
winter
ah well that's a question I get a lot so
there were about 500 above ground
nuclear weapons tests and um so the
people who built nuclear weapons were
fully aware that they were going to
start fires and they knew they did
because they did in Hiroshima Nagasaki
and so the weapons were tested in
deserts or in Islands out of the ocean
so that there wouldn't be anything to
burn they were voiding they were trying
to avoid burning stuff because they knew
they were getting gigantic fires that
they couldn't control
um and so that's so they yeah they blew
up a bunch of rocks in the desert and
blew up some islands which people still
suffer from in the Pacific uh from
radiation poisoning from that uh and uh
but they you know they uh those things
did cause problems from radiation which
was getting around the Earth but it
wasn't enough to be a a threat to human
health it was just starting to become a
problem and so the blast effects were
localized the radiation was spreading
but they hadn't
deposited enough yet to be a global
problem and they had prevented the fires
by testing them in places where there
was nothing to burn
diplomacy is difficult and getting
International agreement is difficult so
could we as a last resort
research some kind of geoengineering
that could attempt to let more sunlight
through to the surface of the Earth and
help alleviate and a nuclear winter
yes well one time the Department of
Defense said the U.S did offer to fund
us to figure out a way to clean the
smoke out of the atmosphere after a
nuclear war
um which is totally impractical I mean
there's it's you know spread out over
the entire Earth and um you know there'd
be no way to reach that smoke and remove
it and the increasing sunlight is Not
Practical I mean I suppose you put big
mirrors in space and focus mirrors down
on the earth which some military guy
would say oh boy I'll really focus it
down and I'll just burn up things with
these mirrors
so probably that's not good to put big
mirrors in space that's the way to warm
things up of their nuclear war
I I think it's not possible and uh that
is much better to just get rid of the
nuclear weapons we don't need it nuclear
weapons the United States is investing
you know huge amounts of money in pieces
of metal that are sitting in the ground
rotting what good do they do they don't
do any good there you can't use them
they have no practical value they're
threatening to life uh and they're
costing a huge amount of money we can't
really stockpile food and we probably
cannot do geoengineering to let in more
sunlight or let more sunlight hit the
surface of the Earth so even though
diplomacy and international agreements
they are difficult
um it's it might be the only only
plausible Way Forward
well I think that has to be the teacher
of humanity I mean we're not going to go
out and colonize the planets and explore
the stars and you know have a good
Society for our children and in the
future
um unless we can find a way for
diplomacy to solve people's problems
and some ways to prevent dictatorships
from arising which lead to these kinds
of situations it's a test of Humanity's
ability to cooperate and and it should
be seen as the first test and if we
can't solve this if we can't pass this
test meaning if we can't
um not kill ourselves with nuclear
weapons well then we can't
travel to other planets in the solar
systems and we can't develop a
flourishing civilization
exactly
will we will we avoid this catastrophe
I think if people pay attention to it
we will solve the problem and we have to
realize that there is opposition
everywhere to anything that involves
money and there's militaries have a huge
amount of money everywhere in the world
uh you know they want to retain their
money and they want to retain their
power and there's all these politicians
who want to you know are more interested
in retaining power than in solving
problems
and um you know so this is the advantage
of democracies you know if that's the
situation you vote them out and you try
to put in people who actually want to
solve the problems and are willing to um
see a future which is different than the
past
you know people
uh you know like things are comfortable
with you know you're you're used to
things being a certain way and it's hard
to adjust the new things unfortunately
it's young people keep coming up and
they don't care about the old things
just to get rid of them and uh develop
new the new things so I'm optimistic
that uh we'll solve all the global
warming problem and you can see the
framework already of how it will be
solved and you can see the framework of
the 1990s how we're going to get into
the mess we're in you know everybody
knew perfectly well we were going to
have overpopulation problems which have
done nothing about which is what's
driving the global climate problem it's
just population
um you can see all the food problems
we're going to encounter in the future
you know there's all kinds of things
that are obviously predictable about the
future from now which you know most
people are not thinking much about so
yeah I'm very optimistic about the
future there's obvious solutions to all
these problems
but we just have to energize people to
achieve them over the opposition that
they will encounter and you know you
can't be stopped by opposition and there
will be opposition from all these
entrenched interests and there has
always been opposition from entrenched
interests and people have always
overcome it and I'm sure they will
overcome all this in the future
Brian I've really enjoyed doing this
interview with you I've learned a lot
and thank you for for spending so much
time with us
sure it's my pleasure yeah it's nice to
talk to you